okay Bell is hot tuna philia look it up
you might learn something
hello is anyone here beauty haha be
sorry beating the Beast comes out today
it's a new 3d be released Lion King did
it huge hit made a ton of money like I
was legitimately surprised how much
money that made but The Lion King is
when my favorite animated films and it
deserves it so it's no wonder that
Disney would want to do the same thing a
few more movies so now I am buting the
beast free release today now I grew up
with this film and let me try to explain
something to you the reason I grew up
with this film is because my sister
loved it and she played it a lot and
then I got into it when I was a kid but
then it got to the point where my sister
would be singing the songs all the time
because my sister has a beautiful voice
and it actually got on my nerves a
little bit so after a while I got kind
of sick of Beauty and the Beast so I
haven't really revisited it since I was
a little boy
hey les oldest time in theaters
everywhere Disney invite you to
experience the story so it was kind of
cool to see it again today because you
know sometimes when you watch a movie
that you haven't seen since you were a
little kid it's like all these little
things keep snapping like oh I remember
that oh my gosh yes that part and that's
kind of what it was like when I was
watching beating the beast today we know
the classic story it's a prince who was
turned into a beast and he's not going
to get back to the prince unless he
finds someone who loves him and he can
love her and appreciate the true value
of love that it's inside has nothing to
do with appearance and we have Belle who
as I said at the beginning is extremely
hot I don't even know what is going on
with my mind when I was watching being
the bee so just like Belle is attractive
people always like you should be
attracted to cartoon characters they
draw her like an incredibly hot woman
she has all the proportions of an
incredibly hot woman so I'm going to be
completely okay with the fact that I
find her incredibly hot so their beauty
and the piece that's even more mature
lots and lots and lots of singing like
more singing than the Lion King for sure
and I'm never really a big fan of
singing in films really there's only a
few films where it doesn't bother me
Lion King is one of them in buting the
beast I like some songs more than others
but some of them I got a little bit
annoyed with and I want them to end up
like they were going on a little bit too
long and that probably has something to
do with the fact that my sister was
singing and playing the soundtrack to it
when I was a little kid so much so that
probably has something to do with it
between 1990 and 1995 you got buting the
Beast Aladdin Lion King and Toy Story
Disney was like on fire I don't know
what they were doing but out of all
those films being the base was my least
favorite always even though I do enjoy
the film I was always a bigger fan of
Aladdin especially The Lion King and Toy
Story of course which is amazing I kind
of laughed a lot at the extreme cornice
of the romance and enchantment and
everything at times when characters kiss
and literal fireworks shoot out of them
into the sky and explode I just find
that a little corny but that's just me
feast
what is dinner without a little music
this January I know I think gasps Dawn's
little sidekick is like in love with
Gaston to be honest because Gaston like
punches that guy in the face breaks his
teeth throws him through walls freezes
him in the cold outside for days and
that guy is still next to Gaston
literally singing him praises I think
there's a romantic subplot that Disney
doesn't want to talk about all jokes
aside buting the bass is a very good
film it was never one of my favorite
Disney movies but I still enjoy the
movie for sure it's out in 3d today and
to be honest I don't know if there's a
point spending that much money to go see
the 3d I mean it's out on blu-ray it's
even on 3d blu-ray so I mean just just
just buy the blu-ray and watch it at
home forever there you go I'm gonna give
buting the Beast a B+ it's wonderful
Beauty and the Beast 3d you guys got it
safest so let me know down below do you
have a favorite Disney movie my favorite
traditional animation is Lion King my
favorite CG animation is the very first
Toy Story if you like this review you
can subscribe to my channel and get
stockman eyes